I'm going to start with an example from unit three. You are
asked to define a procedure union, that takes inputs as two lists
and modifies the first input list to be the set union of
the two input lists. We had the lists of pages to Crawl
as well as the pages that we found linked from the
current site and we wanted to combine those in a new list
of pages to Crawl. So that's what we needed union for. So
that's what we did was define a procedure that took the 2
input lists, and output a list that was their union. This made
sense in CS101. Because we were learning about lists, and how to program
on lists. But it doesn't make a lot of sense if your real
goal is to actually do what we needed for the search engine. So,
for this quiz, what I want you to think about is, which
of the following. Would be the best thing to do if instead of
doing this as a programming exercise to learn to program, you are trying
to build a search engine and realize that what you needed to do
was union the links that you had to search
with the new links that you found from the current
page. Here are the options. Select the one that
you think would be the best one to do first.